custom sneakers are the major wave and
you can do it yourself now at the
fashion show mall rocky is live in the
lab to show us how hi rocky
hey youtube yes we are live in the lab
so i'm going to head over to reuben here
who's actually teaching our lovely maria
customer here from south carolina for
her birthday
she is making her own set of pumas yes
yes so she's actually um sewing down the
tongue right now so if you want to kind
of hit it really softly i'll show you
how to do
it yeah so we're going to be following
the edge keep going
and what we'll be doing is hitting the
edge all the way entirely you can
literally go any direction with this
machine and go through any material this
is so cool so you don't have to actually
know what you're doing you guys you and
your staff are here to teach people how
to do this exactly yeah so yeah i mean
obviously the people that come in they
don't have any experience usually um so
yeah especially here in vegas where
you're getting you know tourists and
locals they're just coming in for a vibe
yeah and it's i mean it's perfect for
all ages so when you like come in it's
like you don't need to learn how to
paint you're like we'll teach you we'll
do it for you you don't need to like
know how to sew like we'll get you on
the machine and i feel like that's kind
of like the you know like the basic
entry level it's like it's awesome all
right so i am entry-level
shoe customizer right now i'm picking my
shoe here yes yes we're going silver
black for the raiders all right so i
feel like maybe i could customize this
with i don't know a skull or something
yeah you could add fabric yeah school
whatever you want and this is obviously
the color the color shoes wall but that
one over there is full of completely
blank shoes that you can do anything you
want to yes exactly yeah so you can do
anything
on any of the shoes but yeah usually the
white kind of silhouettes are where you
would start okay so now we're coming
over here to the work to the actual
workshop we have some people making
their shoes right now so i have to ask
what is your goal here let's show yours
off my inspiration right here was from
this uh
famous customizer yeah yes
go ahead go ahead can you see that
so she is gonna make these
and wear them out yes i love it and
moving on over here this guy has an
elaborate plan okay elaborate plan let's
talk about your shoe yeah okay i was
laying in bed last night and designed
this look at that this is what i came up
with and you're gonna make that here i
am actually going to put
stingray
up the tongue of the shoe
i'm going with the red stingray for the
nike swoosh and up here okay i got we
got a wrap but before we go before we go
reuben just tell people how they can
make a reservation or come in and get a
class yeah so we're doing walk-ins you
can come in and walk in or you can go on
our website majorwaveslabvegas.com
or instagram majorwaveslab all right yep
well welcome to vegas major waves i'm on
this major wave i'm ready to make my
shoe i'll send it back to you